[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم ومرحبا بقناه العربيه انا عبد
الله بن يونس
باش نحكي لكم اليوم على قصتي مع النحت
الحكايه قديمه
نمشي نسرح ولا نلعب مع الاطفال نلعبو
بالطين وبالماء
من غير حتى علم بانه هذا نحت ولا هذا فن
فقط كان الامر لعبه طفوليه ومعاه الوقت مع
القرايه مع الواحد فهمت اللي هي راهي ناحت
واللي هي راهي فن
شهريه البسيطه يلزمني نقوم بواجباتي تجاه
بناتي وحياتي اليوميه ونشتي شويه ماتريال
وهذا وجه اخر من اوجه الصراع وجه اخر من
اوجه
الملحمه البسيطه المتواضعه لقاعه نهر فيها
وحدي هي كيفاش نوصل نطور امكانياتي ونشري
ماتريال برشا حاجات مثلا ناشر ناشر لوح
احذيه في النحت هذه
هذوما عندي وحده اخرى هذه الكبيره وعندي
واحده اخرى اصغر من هذه
البوستالارك نتاع اللحام تاع اللحام
المعدني تعلمته
هذه الورشه
صغيره ما فيها برشا حاجات
مغاره علي بابا منحوتاتي خدمتي لهنا
بديت نخدم
هذه اول تقريبا معناها من بعد بعد
الانقطاع الطويل وقت اللي رجعت اول منحوت
عملت هي هذه هي
المناظر الوطني
المشهور الدغباجي كما تقول الاغنيه هذه
لينا طبعا لينا بالمهني
طفله
الجديره بكل تكريب هذا شكر بالعيد السياسي
الذي اغتيل في 6 فيفري 2013
هذايا هذايا نيلسون مانديلا نيلسون
مانديلا هديه هديه عملته في مرحله نوعا
مارك معناها تلاحظوا حتى الفرق ما بين
هدايا وما بين اللي سبقوه يعني ممكن هذوما
يجسدوا تطور التجربه والتمكن من معناها
تشريح
الجمجمه والوجه والملامح البشريه باش
نوريكم اكبر منحوته خدمتها
اللي هي صديقتي جميله انس جابر منحوته
يعني اكبر من حجم الطبيعي بقليل
برشا وقت تقريبا مغامره كانت مغامره لاني
اول مره نخدم معناها بالحجم هذا بالحجم
الطبيعي تمثال ضخم المميزه في المنحوته
هذه انك خدمتها وحدي فقط بدون مساعده من
اي انسان
[موسيقى]
بعض منحوتات باللي كاملين مخبيين لهنا
هذايا
كاتب التونسي
والمفكر الشهير محمود المسعدي صاحب مولد
النسيان وما ادراك وروايه حدث ابو هريره
قال وهو اشهر من نار على العالم بطبيعه
الحال
تلاحظوا يعني التمكن
معناه التقنيه تطورت بالكذاب معناها في
التمثال هذا خدمته
ريزين
باللي فيه
الشاعر العظيم والفيلسوف محمود درويش
محمود درويش قصه طويله مع الشاعر محمود
درويش ومع محمود درويش الانسان وكذلك قصه
مع نحت محمود درويش لان عملت التمثال
معناه التحدي كان بالحق التحدي
عودته ثلاثه مرات يوصل للمرحله هذه
معناها ما يعجبنيش نعاوده من السفر
المنحوت اللي اللي نحتها لنفسي فقط هي
منحوت صديقيه ضفت عين هذه معناها بالحق
حوطه صغيره يرفعها كف اليد
[موسيقى]
معناها هذه تقريبا
بوجه من الوجوه هي انا اللي يهمني انا هو
انه يعني النحت او الفن بصفه عامه راهو
تجربه ذاتيه يعبر على ذات تاع انسان تشبه
فلان الفلاني في الحياه وفي الوجود بصفه
عامه الفن لا يخضع لقوانين السوق
[موسيقى]